foreign
[Music]
that wants you to colonize planets if
that's driving your entire civilization
there'll come a time
where we both want the same Planet
exactly why is their plan is so much
nicer than our plan you know we should
do
I'm saying we should go over there and
take that plate we should take that
planet let's colonization in a nutshell
yeah there you go if that's the case
then the whole system will implode which
kind of happened with European colonists
England had colonies France had colonies
Spain had colonies and you reach a point
where there's not enough land to go
around and they fight each other for
control of that land right we saw that
play out on Earth's surface
so it could be that whatever is the urge
that would want to make that happen in
the first place has the seeds of its own
unraveling